LaJeunesse: GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANKS TO EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS ROSS LAJEUNESSE,
AND I AM HEAD OF STATE POLICY
FOR THE WESTERN U.S.
HERE AT GOOGLE.
TODAY'S PANEL
IS ON PROPOSITION 8,
WHICH I'M SURE
ALL OF YOU KNOW
IS THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
GOING BEFORE VOTERS
THIS NOVEMBER
WHICH WOULD AMEND
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
TO PROHIBIT
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
[man speaking indistinctly]
LaJeunesse: THAT RAISES
A GOOD POINT.
TODAY'S PANEL IS NOT BALANCED.
AND BY THAT I HAVE NO COMMENT
ON THE MENTAL FACULTIES
OF OUR THREE PANELISTS.
I'M MERELY
STATING THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE OPPONENTS
AND PROPONENTS OF PROP 8
ON TODAY'S PANEL.
THE REASON FOR THAT
IS TODAY'S PANEL
IS HAPPENING
THROUGH THE HARD WORK
OF THE GAYGLERS GROUP
AND OTHER GOOGLERS
WHO OPPOSE PROPOSITION 8.
THE PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
IS SUPPORTING THOSE EFFORTS
AND IS HELPING
TO HOST THE PANEL,
AND WE WOULD DO
THE SAME IF WE WERE APPROACHED
BY PROPONENTS
OF PROPOSITION 8.
SO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE THAT CLARIFICATION
BEFORE WE TURNED IT OVER
TO OUR PANELISTS.
WE HAVE A GREAT GROUP
OF PANELISTS
TODAY.
THEY ARE ALL SUPERSTARS.
I KNOW EACH OF THEM PERSONALLY
TO SOME DEGREE OR ANOTHER.
AND I'M JUST GONNA DO
A BRIEF INTRODUCTION OF EACH
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO THEM.
SO WE'LL HAVE A BRIEF
PRESENTATION FROM EACH PANELIST,
AND THEN I HOPE THAT
WE'LL SPEND A GOOD DEAL OF TIME
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS
AND HAVING A LIVELY DEBATE
ABOUT PROPOSITION 8.
TO MY FAR LEFT
IS STEVE SMITH.
NOW, STEVE IS A BIT
OF A SACRAMENTO LEGEND.
HE IS A PRINCIPAL AT DEWEY
SQUARE GROUP WHERE HE FOCUSES
ON COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
AND CAMPAIGN MANAGEMENT.
HE WAS THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER
FOR BOTH "NO ON 73"
AND "NO ON 85."
CORRECT?
WHICH WERE THE 2005
AND 2006 BALLOT INITIATIVES
DEALING
WITH PARENTAL NOTIFICATION.
STEVE WON
BOTH THOSE CAMPAIGNS.
HE IS NOW
THE CHIEF STRATEGIST
FOR THE "NO ON 8" CAMPAIGN.
IN A PRIOR LIFE,
STEVE WAS SECRETARY OF LABOR
UNDER GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS.
TO STEVE'S RIGHT
IS PATRICK GUERRIERO.
PATRICK IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GILL ACTION FUND,
WHICH IS A DENVER-BASED
ADVOCACY GROUP
WHICH FOCUSES ON NATIONAL ISSUES
SURROUNDING EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR GENDER IDENTITY.
IT'S A BIPARTISAN GROUP,
AND IT'S BEEN AROUND--
YOU'VE BEEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SINCE 2006, CORRECT?
BEFORE THAT, PATRICK
WAS HEAD
OF THE LOG CABIN REPUBLICANS.
AT THE RIPE
OLD AGE OF 25,
PATRICK WAS ELECTED
TO THE MASSACHUSETTS
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
BACK IN 1993.
HE SERVED THREE TERMS
IN THE HOUSE
BEFORE BEING ELECTED MAYOR
OF HIS HOMETOWN
OF MELROSE, MASSACHUSETTS.
AFTER TWO TERMS AS MAYOR,
PATRICK BECAME THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY CANDIDATE
FOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
IN THE NATION'S HISTORY
WHEN MASSACHUSETTS GOVERNOR
JANE SWIFT ASKED HIM
TO JOIN HER TICKET.
THAT WAS IN 2002.
Guerriero: RIGHT.
LaJeunesse: TO PATRICK'S RIGHT
IS KATE KENDELL.
AND I AM PERSONALLY
A GREAT FAN OF KATE'S,
EVER SINCE I HEARD HER GIVE
A FANTASTIC SPEECH
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
WHICH STILL REMAINS
WITH ME TODAY.
SHE'S A BRILLIANT ADVOCATE
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR GAY, LESBIAN, BISEXUAL,
AND TRANSGENDERED INDIVIDUALS.
SHE DOES THAT IN HER CAPACITY
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
NCLR ADVOCATES EQUAL PROTECTION
FOR LGBT INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH LITIGATION,
ADVOCACY,
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION, KATE
IS A MUCH SOUGHT AFTER
NATIONAL COMMENTATOR
ON THESE ISSUES.
SHE'S APPEARED
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
CNN, NPR.
PRETTY MUCH ANY PUBLICATION
ONE CAN THINK OF,
KATE HAS BEEN THERE.
AND KATE IS GOING
TO START US OFF TODAY.
SO I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO YOU.
Kendell: GREAT.
THANK YOU, ROSS.
LaJeunesse: WHY DON'T WE JUST
WELCOME OUR PANELISTS FIRST?
THIS IS GREAT.
[applause]
Kendell: AND I JUST WANNA
POINT OUT THAT ROSS
MADE THOSE
VERY GENEROUS INTRODUCTIONS
OF ALL THREE OF US
WITH NOT ONE NOTE.
THAT'S...
BIG BRAINS,
YOU GOOGLE PEOPLE.
ALL OF YOU.
IT IS GREAT TO BE HERE
AND TO BE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT I THINK IS--
I THINK THE MOST--
WELL, CERTAINLY IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT FIGHT THAT
I HAVE FACED AS A MEMBER
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PROGRESSIVE FIGHTS
WE'VE EVER FACED
IN THIS NATION.
AND I THINK ITS POTENTIAL
TO TURN THE TIDE
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
TO REALLY CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE
FOR EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY
REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
IS REALLY ENORMOUS,
AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THE STAKES COULDN'T BE HIGHER.
IT'S TRUE,
AS ROSS POINTED OUT,
THAT WE DON'T HAVE PROPONENTS
OF PROP 8 ON THIS PANEL.
BUT I DID GROW UP MORMON
IN UTAH,
SO IF ANYONE WANTS TO--
THE ARGUMENT'S PRESENTED--
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO GO BACK TO MY ROOTS
BECAUSE THE CHURCH
OF MY CHILDHOOD IS A VERY
VIGOROUS PROPONENT
OF PROP 8.
AND WE'VE SEEN A LOT
OF THEIR MESSAGING.
AND I'VE BEEN
IN SOME CONVERSATIONS
WITH SOME OF MY OWN
FAMILY MEMBERS
ABOUT PROP 8, AND IT DOES
STIMULATE SIGNIFICANT VIEWS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT ONE THING
THAT IS BECOMING CLEAR
IS THAT PEOPLE
ARE RECOGNIZING
THAT WE NOW
LIVE IN A STATE
THAT TREATS
ALL PEOPLE EQUALLY
WHEN IT COMES
TO THE RIGHT TO MARRY.
EVERYONE IN THIS STATE CAN MARRY
THE PERSON THAT THEY LOVE.
THAT IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT--
[applause]
THAT IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT RIGHT.
IT IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT WAY
OF BEING.
OF UNDERSTANDING
ONE'S SELF
AND ONE'S RELATIONSHIP.
NO ONE SHOULD GROW UP FEELING
AS IF THEIR RELATIONSHIP
IS SUBSTANDARD.
THAT THEIR RELATIONSHIP
DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT THEIR LOVE IS NOT REGARDED
EQUALLY UNDER THE LAW.
AND WE NOW LIVE IN A STATE
WHERE THAT IS THE CASE,
AND IT IS A TRULY LANDMARK
AND HISTORIC MOMENT.
SO WHAT VOTERS ARE FACING,
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IN SOME OF THE MESSAGING
AND THE POLLING
THAT STEVE'S GONNA TALK ABOUT
IN A FEW MINUTES--
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT FACED
WITH THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER FOLKS ARE REALLY
WILLING TO ELIMINATE
THE RIGHT OF SAME-SEX COUPLES
TO MARRY--
WE ARE FINDING THAT REGARDLESS
OF HOW PEOPLE FEEL
ABOUT SAME-SEX COUPLES MARRYING,
THEY REALLY DO NOT HAVE
THE POLITICAL STOMACH--
IT IS TRENDING THIS WAY,
ALTHOUGH IT'S VERY,
VERY CLOSE--
TO ELIMINATE
THAT FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVEN'T SEEN
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE
OF THE INITIATIVE,
IT'S VERY SIMPLE AND THIS IS HOW
IT WILL APPEAR ON THE BALLOT.
ARGUMENT LANGUAGE
THAT EVERYONE WILL BE GETTING
IN THEIR MAILBOXES
THE FIRST WEEK IN OCTOBER.
IT'S PROPOSITION 8.
THIS IS THE TITLE:
"ELIMINATES RIGHT
OF SAME-SEX COUPLES TO MARRY."
AND THEN, OF COURSE,
THESE ARE THE STAKES
THAT MAKE IT SO HIGH.
IT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
THE HIGHEST LAW
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN IT'S 13 QUICK WORDS.
"CHANGES CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
TO ELIMINATE THE RIGHT
OF SAME-SEX COUPLES TO MARRY."
AND THIS IS THE KEY LANGUAGE:
"PROVIDES THAT ONLY MARRIAGE
BETWEEN A MAN AND A WOMAN
IS VALID OR RECOGNIZED
IN CALIFORNIA."
NOW THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE
ARE VOTING ON,
AND IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE LANGUAGE IS
AND THAT IT'S NOT A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE SAYING
YOU HAVE TO BE CELEBRATING
THE RIGHT OF SAME-SEX COUPLES
TO MARRY,
ALTHOUGH FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE GOTTEN MARRIED
OR ATTENDED WEDDINGS,
IT'S A VERY MOVING
AND CELEBRATORY EXPERIENCE.
THE ISSUE IS,
ARE YOU WILLING TO ELIMINATE
THIS VERY IMPORTANT,
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
FOR A WHOLE CATEGORY
OF CALIFORNIANS?
"WHY VOTE NO?"
AND THIS IS EASY MESSAGING
THAT YOU ALL COULD WRITE
YOURSELVES,
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO PROP 8,
THAT WE DON'T ELIMINATE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT IT'S WRONG TO TAKE
A CATEGORY OF PEOPLE AND SAY,
"YOU ARE GOING
TO BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
"THAN ANYBODY ELSE BASED
ON A FACTOR
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH YOUR ABILITY."
THAT SAME-SEX COUPLES
AND INDIVIDUALS
ARE PART OF CALIFORNIA.
A PART OF THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE.
THIS IS PART OF WHAT MAKES
THIS STATE GREAT.
PART OF THE DIVERSITY
THAT MAKES THIS STATE GREAT.
WE HEAR ARGUMENTS
FROM THE OTHER SIDE,
AND THE MAIN ARGUMENTS
THAT THEY ARE MAKING--
ONE OF THE KEY ONES--
IS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS MUSCULAR
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
THAT PROTECT SAME-SEX COUPLES.
WE DON'T NEED MARRIAGE.
MARRIAGE SHOULD JUST BE
BETWEEN A MAN AND A WOMAN.
WELL, WE ALL KNOW--
WHO HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS--
THAT IT'S NOT THE SAME.
IT'S NOT THE SAME VOCABULARY.
THERE'S NOT
A COMMON UNDERSTANDING.
COUPLES WHO ARE
IN DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
STILL FACE ENDLESS QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHO THEY REALLY ARE
TO EACH OTHER.
AND WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
WE NOW HAVE THE RIGHT TO MARRY
IN THIS STATE, AND ELIMINATING
THAT FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE VOTING ON,
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
VOTERS SHOULD VOTE "YES" ON.
WE ARE DOING BETTER THAN THAT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR POLLING RIGHT NOW--
AND I KNOW PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
A LOT OF PUBLIC POLLS THAT
SHOW US SIGNIFICANTLY AHEAD.
THE "NO" VOTE SIGNIFICANTLY
AHEAD OF THE "YES" VOTE.
WE ARE MUCH CLOSER THAN SOME
OF THOSE POLLS SHOW.
AND THERE'S ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT METHODOLOGIES
THAT STEVE
CAN TALK ABOUT MORE,
BUT WHAT YOU ALL
NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO UNDERSTAND IN THIS FIGHT,
IS THAT WHILE
IT'S IMMINENTLY WINNABLE,
IT IS A DEAD HEAT.
AND THE "UNDECIDED" UNIVERSE
IS MUCH SMALLER
THAN ON USUALLY ANY
OTHER QUESTION AT THIS TIME
AND THOSE "UNDECIDEDS"
ARE THE FOLKS
WHO WE REALLY NEED TO REACH,
AND WHO NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THE MESSAGE
OF WHAT THE HARM WOULD BE.
THIS IS NOT A NEUTRAL VOTE.
A VOTE TO ELIMINATE
THE RIGHTS OF ANY CATEGORY
OF PEOPLE DOES HARM,
AND IT CERTAINLY DOES HARM--
WILL DO HARM--
TO SAME-SEX COUPLES,
AND THEIR FAMILIES,
AND PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THEM
IN TERMS OF THEIR STATUS
UNDER THE LAW.
SO THAT UNDECIDED POOL,
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S A SMALL UNIVERSE
OF DONORS.
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE.
THEY'RE NOT
IN ANY ONE DEMOGRAPHIC.
THEY'RE ALL UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
IN A NECK-AND-NECK RACE,
AND AS WE GO
INTO THE ADVERTISING SEASON,
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY,
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THE MUSCULAR
CAMPAIGN TO BE UP,
TO BE UP EARLY, AND TO MAKE SURE
WE CAPTURE THOSE UNDECIDEDS.
SO THE CAMPAIGN STRUCTURE.
THERE'S NOT ANY CAMPAIGN
THAT CAN EVER WIN
IN CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
BASED ON JUST VOLUNTEERS,
OR JUST THOSE OF US
WHO ARE LEADERS
ON ANY PARTICULAR ISSUE,
WHETHER IT'S RACIAL JUSTICE
AND AFFIRMATIVE ACTION,
OR WHETHER IT'S
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION
AS STEVE HAS WORKED ON BEFORE,
YOU NEED PROFESSIONALS.
AND WE KNEW THAT EARLY ON,
SO WE WENT TO TWO
OF THE BEST OPERATIONS AND
THE BEST SHOPS IN THE COUNTRY
TO BE THE PROFESSIONALS
ON OUR CAMPAIGN.
YOU'LL HEAR IN A MOMENT
FROM DEWEY SQUARE.
ROSS OBVIOUSLY DID GREAT JUSTICE
TO STEVE'S CREDENTIALS
AS OUR GENERAL CONSULTANT,
AND YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM HIM.
WORKING HAND-IN-HAND
WITH STEVE
IS OGILVY PUBLIC RELATIONS--
ALSO HAS WON NUMEROUS CAMPAIGNS
STATEWIDE IN CALIFORNIA--
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MESSAGING
THAT THE VOTERS SEE--
HOW YOU WIN CAMPAIGNS
IN CALIFORNIA
IS THOSE ADS THAT PEOPLE SEE.
EVEN THOUGH WE ALL,
BY NOVEMBER 4th,
WILL BE COMPLETELY SICK
OF THEM,
THAT MESSAGING FRAMES HOW
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND OGILVY,
THEY'RE PROS AT DOING THIS,
AND WE FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT WITH THEM.
WE HAVE UNPRECEDENTED
PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
AND I'M JUST GONNA GO
THROUGH THESE QUICKLY.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO READ 'EM ALL
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST--
THERE'S SO MANY
WHO ARE SUPPORTING.
AND THIS BUSINESS LIST
IS ONLY PARTIAL.
THERE ARE MANY MORE
ORGANIZATIONS,
AND BUSINESSES,
AND CORPORATIONS
THAT ARE IN PROCESS
IN MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT SUPPORTING PROP 8.
WE BELIEVE THIS LIST
WILL BE VERY LONG.
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IT RUNS THE GAMUT.
IT'S NOT JUST
LGBT ORGANIZATIONS.
IT'S EVERYONE WHO WANTS
TO LIVE IN A STATE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TREATED FAIRLY
AND EQUALLY.
THOSE ARE JUST
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES.
THAT'S ACTUALLY
A CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPLE.
THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHO PEOPLE MARRY.
GOVERNMENT STAYS
OUTTA THAT BUSINESS.
THE LAW TREATS
EVERYONE EQUALLY.
AND SO WE HAVE SUPPORT
FROM ALL SORTS
OF CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS,
FROM MAINSTREAM ORGANIZATIONS,
FROM RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS.
IT HAS REALLY BEEN
A VERY GRATIFYING CAMPAIGN
TO BE INVOLVED IN.
SO FUNDRAISING--BECAUSE THIS
IS WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO, FOLKS.
AND I WISH IT WASN'T
JUST ABOUT THE MONEY.
I WISH IT WAS ABOUT,
YOU KNOW,
"LET ME JUST HAVE
A CONVERSATION WITH YOU."
AND "LET'S WORK IT ALL OUT."
AND "LET ME GET YOU
TO VOTE 'NO'."
BUT IT'S ABOUT MONEY.
AND SO FAR WE'VE RAISED
OVER $10 MILLION.
THAT IS UNPRECEDENTED
FOR A GAY ISSUE IN THE COUNTRY.
NEVER BEFORE HAS THAT KIND
OF MONEY BEEN RAISED
FROM 32,000 DONORS.
NEVER BEFORE
FROM THAT MANY DONORS.
BUT YOU CAN ALL DO THE MATH.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE
A LOT MORE PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO HAVEN'T GIVEN,
THAT CAN GIVE,
AND HAVE THE CAPACITY TO GIVE.
AND THAT $10 MILLION,
NOT GONNA DO IT.
WE KNEW
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
THIS WAS GONNA BE
A $20 MILLION CAMPAIGN.
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE SEEING
FROM OUR OPPOSITION
IS NOT ONLY THAT IT'S GONNA BE
A $20 MILLION CAMPAIGN,
BUT IT'S PROBABLY GONNA BE
A 24 OR 25,
MAYBE $26 MILLION CAMPAIGN.
AND THAT'S JUST COLD,
HARD FACT.
WE BELIEVE WE CAN RAISE IT.
BUT IT WILL TAKE PEOPLE WHO'VE
NEVER WRITTEN A CHECK BEFORE
TO A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
FOR US TO GET TO THAT MARK.
WHAT WE'RE UP AGAINST--
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS MONEY
POURING INTO THE OTHER SIDE,
MAINLY FROM, SO FAR,
THE KNIGHTS OF COLUMBUS,
THE MORMON CHURCH,
AND FOCUS ON THE FAMILY.
THESE ARE VERY LOW DOLLARS.
THEY'LL BE FOUR, FIVE,
SIX, TEN, MAYBE 20 TIMES THAT
BY THE TIME WE'RE DONE.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO MATCH THEM
DOLLAR-FOR-DOLLAR.
THE MEDIA BUY TO DO THIS--
WE GO UP OCTOBER 6th
IN ALL THESE MAJOR MARKETS.
AND WE'RE IN ALL THOSE MARKETS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
ALL OUR UNDECIDED VOTERS ARE.
I WISH THEY WERE ALL IN A SMALL
NEIGHBORHOOD IN LOS GATOS.
THAT WOULD MAKE IT
SO MUCH EASIER.
BUT THEY ARE EVERYWHERE.
THEY'RE IN EVERY AGE GROUP.
THEY'RE BOTH REPUBLICAN
AND THEY'RE DEMOCRAT.
THEY'RE LATINO.
THEY'RE AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THEY'RE WHITE.
THEY'RE BLUE-COLLAR.
THEY'RE WEALTHY.
THEY'RE OLDER.
I MEAN, THEY ARE EVERYONE.
THE "UNDECIDED" UNIVERSE
IS EVERYONE THAT YOU KNOW
IN YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE,
AND THOSE ARE THE FOLKS
THAT WE NEED TO REACH,
AND THAT'S THE CHALLENGE
IN THIS CAMPAIGN,
TO REACH THEM ALL
AND TO MOVE THEM TO A "NO."
DONALD WILDMON,
WHO IS PRESIDENT
OF THE AMERICAN FAMILY
ASSOCIATION--
ONE OF, I WILL SAY,
THE MOST VITRIOLICLY NASTY
ANTI-GAY ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
AROUND THE IDEA
OF LESBIAN AND GAY PEOPLE
MARRYING,
AND THEY'RE NOT ANTI-GAY.
I WANNA BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE CAN BE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE IDEA
OF SAME-SEX COUPLES MARRYING,
AND THAT DOES NOT
MAKE THEM ANTI-GAY.
DONALD WILDMON,
ANTI-GAY.
AND HE HAS MADE
A LIFE'S WORK
OUT OF REALLY PUTTING FORWARD--
SPEWING FORWARD--
THE MOST VICIOUS,
FEAR-MONGERING
ABOUT LESBIAN AND GAY PEOPLE,
AND THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS.
"IF WE LOSE IN CALIFORNIA,
"IF THEY DEFEAT THE MARRIAGE
AMENDMENT, WE'RE DONE.
THEY'VE WON THE CULTURE WARS."
NOW, FOLKS, IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO HAVE THAT WIN.
BUT IF HE IS FRAMING IT
THAT WAY--
A MAN WHO HAS MADE
A LIFE'S WORK OF DEMONIZING
LESBIAN AND GAY PEOPLE--
THEN IF YOU CARE
ABOUT ANYONE WHO IS LGBT,
IF YOU ARE LGBT YOURSELF,
IF YOU CARE
ABOUT PROGRESSIVE ISSUES,
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S AT STAKE AS WELL.
BECAUSE HE'S GOT THE PASSION,
AND THAT'S HOW YOU FUND
AND SUPPORT THIS CAMPAIGN.
WE'VE GOTTA HAVE
THE SAME THING.
SO OUR MESSAGE IS A SIMPLE ONE.
DON'T ELIMINATE
THE RIGHT TO MARRY FOR ANYONE.
IT'S A "VOTE NO" ON PROP 8,
AND GET EVERYONE YOU KNOW
TO DO THE SAME.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
NATIONAL IMPLICATIONS
TO WHAT WE'RE FACING.
AND PATRICK GUERRIERO
AND GILL ACTION
UNDERSTANDS THOSE RAMIFICATIONS
AND HOW THEY FEED IN--
AND HOW CALIFORNIA FEEDS INTO
THAT AND EFFECTS THE COUNTRY
PROBABLY BETTER THAN ANYONE
IN THE NATION.
HE IS A DEAR COLLEAGUE, AND IT
IS REALLY A PLEASURE FOR ME
TO ACTUALLY SEE YOU IN PERSON,
SINCE WE'VE BEEN EXCHANGING
THREE OR FOUR EMAILS
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE DAY
FOR THE LAST THREE MONTHS
AS WE WORK ON THE CAMPAIGN.
SO I'LL LET PATRICK TALK
ABOUT THE NATIONAL PICTURE.
Guerriero:
THANKS, KATE.
THE, UM, YOU KNOW, KATE--
[applause]
KATE NOT ONLY BRINGS
OBVIOUSLY GREAT INTELLECT
TO THIS ARGUMENT, BUT ALSO
A GREAT DEAL OF EMOTION.
AND IT'S HARD NOT TO BE
EMOTIONAL AND PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS.
I KNOW LAST NIGHT OVER DINNER--
HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH SOME FOLKS,
AND IT'S A SENSE THAT WE ARE
ON THE BALLOT.
I MEAN, THIS IS NOT A BALLOT--
COMING FROM CALIFORNIA,
YOU'RE USED TO A LOT
OF BALLOT INITIATIVES.
THIS IS A UNIQUE ONE
IN THAT HUMAN BEINGS, US,
OUR FRIENDS, OUR NEIGHBORS,
OUR PARTNERS ARE ON THE BALLOT.
AND OUR DIGNITY, OUR BASIC
FAIRNESS IS ON THE BALLOT.
THERE'S A LOT OF EMOTION
THAT COMES WITH THAT.
AND FOR THOSE OF US
WHO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
LIVING THROUGH THE KIND
OF CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
OF OUR GENERATION,
IT'S DIFFICULT NOT TO HAVE
THE BLOOD PRESSURE GO UP,
AND TO BE ANXIOUS,
AND TO COME AT THIS CAMPAIGN
FROM A VERY,
VERY EMOTIONAL PLACE.
WHICH IS WHY I
OFTEN BECOME THE, UM,
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PERSON
IN THE ROOM
BECAUSE I COME FROM A UNIVERSE
IN RUNNING GILL ACTION--
WHICH IS A ORGANIZATION
THAT INVESTS
IN EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
IN HARDCORE POLITICAL WORK
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
I COME FROM A LENS THAT
IS REMARKABLY DISPASSIONATE
SOMETIMES, UNEMOTIONAL,
DEEPLY DATA-DRIVEN,
DEEPLY RESEARCH-DRIVEN,
DEEPLY POLL-DRIVEN,
BECAUSE THERE ARE
A WHOLE LOT OF BATTLES
THAT ARE BEING FOUGHT
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT MATTER
TO NOT ONLY LGBT PEOPLE,
BUT PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE NATION.
AND IN DOING SO,
PART OF OUR JOB
IS TO GO BACK TO OUR DONOR,
AND HIS NAME IS TIM GILL,
WHO'S ONE OF THE MOST
GENEROUS PHILANTHROPISTS
AND POLITICAL INVESTORS
IN THE NATION,
AND A GROUP OF OTHER DONORS,
GENEROUS DONORS
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT WE GIVE
POLITICAL COUNSEL TO,
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THEM
ABOUT THE PLACES WHERE
THEIR MONEY, IF INVESTED,
CAN MAKE THE MOST DIFFERENCE
IN THE FASTEST AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND WE HAVE LITERALLY
TRAVELED THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE LOOKED
AT EVERY BALLOT INITIATIVE.
AT EVERY STATE RACE.
WE'VE LOOKED
AT ALL THE DIFFERENT DYNAMICS
THAT HAPPEN IN AN ELECTION YEAR,
AND WE'VE DECIDED
REALLY RECENTLY, TO BE HONEST,
THAT THIS IS SINGULARLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
HAPPENING IN NOVEMBER
OTHER THAN THE FEDERAL ELECTION.
WE BELIEVE THIS
HAS HUGE RAMIFICATIONS,
NOT ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA AND
EVERY SINGLE LGBT FAMILY HERE,
BUT SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT NOT BE AWARE OF IS THAT
NOT ONLY WOULD THIS BE
THE FIRST STATE EVER
TO HAVE THE PUBLIC AFFIRM
THE BASIC FAIRNESS
FOR ALL FAMILIES,
BUT THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF STATES THAT
LITERALLY ARE WAITING
AND WATCHING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS STATE.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A FEW EXAMPLES.
IN NEW YORK,
THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR ARE VERY CLOSE
TO REACHING A POINT
WHERE THEY COULD PASS
MARRIAGE EQUALITY
AND HAVE THE GOVERNOR
SIGN IT NEXT YEAR.
THEY'RE WATCHING
AND WAITING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN NEW JERSEY,
WE HAVE A LEGISLATURE
RIGHT ON THE EDGE OF PASSING
MARRIAGE EQUALITY,
AND THE GOVERNOR IS WATCHING
WHAT HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THIS WILL
PASS THE MUSTER OF THE PUBLIC.
EVEN IN PLACES LIKE IOWA,
THE COURT IS ABOUT TO RULE
OVER THE NEXT 8-12 MONTHS
IN WHAT COULD BE
A HISTORIC DECISION
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY
ABOUT WHETHER
TO AFFIRM THE RIGHTS
OF SAME-SEX COUPLES
IN IOWA TO MARRY.
AND YOU BETTER BELIEVE
THAT COURT,
AND THAT LEGISLATURE,
AND THE PUBLIC IN IOWA
IS TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
IN ANY STATE BEFORE
A SINGLE BALLOT INITIATIVE
THAT WOULD IMPACT MORE PEOPLE
AND IMPACT MORE STATES.
AND WE HAVE ACTUALLY TOLD
A NUMBER OF OUR INVESTORS
AND DONORS THAT WE TALKED TO
THAT WE ACTUALLY THINK
THIS WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER WE'RE ABLE
TO REALIZE FULL EQUALITY FOR
LGBT FAMILIES IN THIS COUNTRY
OVER THE NEXT 15 YEARS,
OR WHETHER IT'S GOING TAKE
TWO OR THREE GENERATIONS.
15 YEARS VERSUS 50 YEARS.
THIS RACE ACTUALLY HAS
THAT TYPE OF EXPONENTIAL EFFECT
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
AND WHEN YOU ADD
TO THAT THAT OUR ENEMIES
ARE OFTEN THE ENEMIES
OF THE PRO-CHOICE MOVEMENT,
OFTEN THE ENEMIES
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT--
WHEN YOU HEAR DON WILDMON
SAYING THIS IS REALLY
GROUND ZERO
FOR THE CULTURE WAR,
THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS AT STAKE
IN NOVEMBER
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE'VE DETERMINED THIS
TO BE THE MOST IMPORTANT RACE
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THAT ALONE THOUGH WOULD NOT LEAD
US TO TELL PEOPLE TO INVEST.
THERE ARE A LOT
OF REALLY IMPORTANT RACES
THAT DON'T MEET
THE CRITERIA TO WIN.
AND SO WE DID A FULL ANALYSIS
OF THIS BALLOT INITIATIVE.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS
CAN YOU WIN BASED ON THE DATA
YOU HAVE AROUND POLLING
AND THE RESEARCH YOU HAVE?
AND THE ANSWER
IS UNEQUIVOCALLY YES.
THE POLLING SHOWS, DEPENDING
ON WHOSE POLL YOU BELIEVE,
THAT WE'RE WITHIN FIVE
TO TEN POINTS UP OR DOWN
DEPENDING ON WHAT
DAY OF THE WEEK IT IS.
THE CLIMATE.
AND SO THIS IS A--
AND I THINK, KATE,
YOU'VE TERMED IT WELL--
A DEAD HEAT.
A COMPLETE DEAD HEAT
THAT COULD EITHER WIN
BY A COUPLE POINTS
OR LOSE BY A COUPLE POINTS.
THE SECOND QUESTION
IS DOES THIS STATE
AND ITS GENEROUS CITIZENS
HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO RAISE THE MONEY NECESSARY
TO WAGE A FULL-FLEDGED CAMPAIGN?
IN A LOT OF STATES
THE ANSWER IS "NO."
IN THIS STATE
THE ANSWER IS "YES,"
EXCEPT THAT THERE IS
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF URGENCY
BECAUSE, LITERALLY,
TV TIME NEEDS TO BE PURCHASED
WITHIN THE NEXT
TWO TO THREE WEEKS.
AND I WILL BE SO RAW
AS TO SAY THIS.
FROM THE NUMBERS
WE HAVE SEEN AND ANALYZED,
IF OUR OPPONENTS OUT-RAISE US,
WE WILL LOSE.
THAT'S A TOUGH THING TO SAY.
BUT WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT'S THE CASE,
AND THAT IS A LEVEL
OF URGENCY AROUND MAKING SURE
WE CAN FUND
A FULL-FLEDGED CAMPAIGN.
THE NEXT QUESTION WE ASKED
OURSELVES IS THAT
CAN THE LGBT MOVEMENT,
THAT HAS SUCH TREMENDOUS HEROES,
MOVE FROM JUST BEING
A PROGRESSIVE ADVOCACY MOVEMENT
TO ONE THAT ACTUALLY EMPOWERS
SMART, STRATEGIC,
POLITICAL THINKERS
TO MAKE HARDCORE POLITICAL
CHOICES TO WIN AN ELECTION?
AND WE'RE CONVINCED
AFTER TAKING A REAL CLOSE LOOK
AT THIS CAMPAIGN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
THAT THEY'VE HIRED
SOME REALLY SMART PEOPLE.
THE BEST AVAILABLE TO RUN
THE SMARTEST CAMPAIGN,
AND THAT THE LGBT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ALMOST COMPLETELY THERE
IN TERMS OF PUTTING EGO
AND ORGANIZATION ASIDE,
AND MICROMANAGEMENT ASIDE, AND
ALLOWING THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
TO BE EMPOWERED TO MAKE
THE TOUGH CHOICES THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE BETWEEN NOW
AND ELECTION DAY.
AND THEN THE LAST PIECE
WE ALWAYS LOOK FOR IS TRENDS.
WHAT WE KNOW IS
THE PUBLIC WITNESSED
A LOT OF WONDERFUL PEOPLE
GETTING MARRIED ONLY WEEKS AGO
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
IN THIS STATE.
AND THE PUBLIC WAS TOLD BY
THE FAR-RIGHT THAT THE LOCUSTS
AND PLAGUE WOULD BE HITTING
CALIFORNIA WITHIN DAYS.
SEEMS LIKE WE'VE DONE OKAY
SINCE THOSE MARRIAGES.
I DON'T THINK
ANY HETEROSEXUAL MARRIAGES
HAVE BEEN THREATENED.
SO ALL THE DOOM AND GLOOM
THAT WE ALSO HEARD
IN MASSACHUSETTS,
AND WE ALSO HEARD
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA,
DIDN'T HAPPEN HERE.
AND SO THERE SEEMS TO BE
THIS UNDERLYING BELIEF
THAT THERE IS GOOD ENERGY,
THERE IS A GOOD FEELING HERE,
BUT IT'S GONNA BE DAMN CLOSE
HOWEVER WE LOOK AT IT.
THE GOOD NEWS,
UNDER A FAIRLY UNEMOTIONAL,
DATA-DRIVEN,
POLL-DRIVEN ANALYSIS
OF THE STATUS OF THIS CAMPAIGN,
WE ARE WELL POSITIONED TO WIN,
IF WE CAN RAISE THE MONEY
AND DELIVER THE MESSAGE
INTO THE LIVING ROOMS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND ONE OF THE PERSONS
BEST CAPABLE OF DOING THAT
IS STEVE SMITH.
HE'S A FAIRLY MODEST--
AT LEAST MOST OF THE TIME.
BUT STEVE HAS BEEN
DOING BALLOT INITIATIVES
FOR THREE DECADES.
I KIDDED EARLIER
THAT YOU STARTED
WHEN YOU WERE FIVE,
I GUESS.
FOR THREE DECADES,
HE'S BEEN DOING
BALLOT INITIATIVES.
HE'S DONE OVER A DOZEN "NO ON"
CERTAIN BALLOT INITIATIVE
CAMPAIGNS, AND HE'S WON
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
AND SO WE'VE PUT THE,
KIND OF, THE TRUST
AND THE CONFIDENCE INTO ONE
OF THE BEST PEOPLE POSSIBLE
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN WIN.
STEVE.
Smith: HOWDY.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO KNOW
THAT A REPUBLICAN
FROM MASSACHUSETTS
AND A DEMOCRAT FROM CALIFORNIA
CAN HANG OUT.
GLAD YOU'RE ON MY LEFT.
YEAH, WELL, I'LL ALWAYS BE
ON YOUR LEFT, BROTHER.
[chuckling]
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE,
AND THEN WHAT
WE GOTTA GET DONE
IN THE NEXT VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME REFERENCES
HERE ABOUT 40/40/20.
THAT REALLY IS WHERE IT IS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVEN POLLS
DONE IN THE LAST--
ABOUT NINE OR TEN WEEKS.
SOME OF THOSE ARE PUBLIC.
SOME OF THOSE ARE PRIVATE.
EVERY ONE OF THEM
HAS COME BACK.
THEY HAD
DIFFERENT RESULTS,
BUT EVERY ONE OF THEM HAS COME
BACK WITHIN THAT 40/40 MARGIN.
SOMETIMES WE'RE AHEAD.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE AHEAD.
BUT THERE'S ALWAYS
THE SAME 20%
SWIMMING AROUND OUT THERE.
THAT'S THE 20%
THAT WE NEED TO TALK TO,
THAT WE NEED TO CONVINCE
IN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
HOW DO YOU CONVINCE THEM?
WE ARE NOW--I MEAN, THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF PREPARATION.
KATE'S BEEN GETTING READY
FOR THIS CAMPAIGN, WHAT,
THREE OR FOUR YEARS?
man: ALL HER LIFE?
Smith: YEAH.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT WAY
TO LOOK AT IT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT WE'RE NOW DOWN TO IT.
27 DAYS FROM NOW,
THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE ABSENTEE VOTERS
WILL GO HOME
TO A BALLOT IN YOUR MAILBOX.
30 DAYS LATER,
THE ELECTION HAPPENS.
WE'RE THERE.
NOW THE THING
THAT WE ALL NEED TO DO
IS TALK TO VOTERS.
AND IN THIS ELECTION
IN CALIFORNIA,
THERE WILL BE 12.5,
12.6 MILLION VOTERS.
MORE VOTERS THAN HAVE
EVER CAST A BALLOT
IN ANY SINGLE STATE
IN ANY ELECTION IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
BECAUSE THE TR--
I MEAN, LOOK,
LET'S FACE IT.
THE PRESIDENTIAL
IS ENERGIZING, FOLKS.
THERE'S GONNA BE
A HUGE TURNOUT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT.
WE HAVE TO TALK
TO THOSE 20% OF THE VOTERS
AND GET THEM
TO COME OUR WAY.
I'VE TOLD THIS CLIENT THIS
SEVERAL TIMES.
WHEN I MANAGED
THE "NO ON PROP 85" CAMPAIGN
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
TWO YEARS AGO,
LITERALLY, THE FIRST
CAMPAIGN POLL THAT SAID
THAT WE WERE AHEAD, I READ
AT THE BREAKFAST TABLE
ON ELECTION DAY.
WE HAD BEEN BEHIND THE ENTIRE
TIME IN CLOSING THE GAP.
THIS IS NOT THAT KIND
OF SITUATION.
I'VE SEEN POLLS
SAYING WE'RE AHEAD.
I'VE SEEN POLLS SAYING
WE'RE SLIGHTLY BEHIND.
BUT WE'RE GONNA DO THIS
RIGHT UP UNTIL THE WIRE,
AND THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GONNA WIN AGAIN
IS TO TALK TO THOSE VOTERS.
HOW DO YOU TALK
TO VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA?
IT'S CALLED TELEVISION
AND RADIO.
'CAUSE THERE'S
TOO DAMN MANY OF US
TO DO IT ANY OTHER WAY,
FRANKLY.
THIS JUST
IS NOT NEW HAMPSHIRE.
THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO IT.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED
TO GO UP ON THE TELEVISION,
WE NEED TO BUY MORE ADVERTISING
THAN THEY'RE BUYING,
AND WE NEED TO DELIVER
OUR MESSAGE.
KATE TALKED
ABOUT TALKING TO PEOPLE.
YOU CANNOT ELIMINATE
THE RIGHT TO MARRY.
YOU HAVE TO ALLOW
COMMITTED COUPLES
WHO ARE IN LOVE
WITH EACH OTHER
TO GO OUT AND GET MARRIED.
WE'RE THERE NOW.
WE'RE THERE
AFTER A HUGE FIGHT.
WE NOW NEED TO STAY THERE.
AND IN CALIFORNIA,
THE NICE PART ABOUT THIS IS
IT'S ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED
IN SO MANY FORUMS
THAT IF WE WIN THIS,
IT'S DONE.
REMEMBER, THE LEGISLATURE'S
PASSED IT TWICE.
THE GOVERNOR NOW SUPPORTS
OUR SIDE OF THE ISSUE.
THE COURT HAS NOW RULED,
THERE'S ONLY ONE OTHER BODY
OUT THERE
LEFT TO DECIDE.
IT'S CALLED THE VOTERS.
SO IF THE VOTERS
SAY NO ON 8,
WE'RE DONE.
THERE IS NO MORE PLACE
FOR THE OTHER SIDE
TO PLAY THEIR GAMES.
THAT MEANS WE NEED
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEM.
ARE WE GONNA GET 1/4 MILLION,
1/2 MILLION
VOLUNTEER PHONE CALLS MADE?
YES.
ARE WE GONNA DO MAIL
AND PHONE TO PROBABLY
A MILLION AND A HALF,
2 MILLION VOTERS?
YES.
BUT THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GONNA
REACH OUT AND TOUCH 12.4,
12.5 MILLION VOTERS
IS ON THE TELEVISION,
INTO FOLKS' LIVING ROOMS,
TO SOME DEGREE
ON THE INTERNET.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE GET TO THOSE FOLKS.
SO THAT'S HOW
WE HAVE TO DO IT.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA.
WE GOTTA WIN THIS FIGHT.
WE GOTTA GO UP
ON THE TELEVISION.
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GONNA DO IT.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
IN THE LAST 57 DAYS--
AND THAT'S THE WAY
I WOULD CHARACTERIZE THAT 20%.
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT
THIS IS NOT AN EASY DECISION.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY SUPPORT
GAY MARRIAGE.
IN FACT, MOST OF THAT UNDECIDED
PROBABLY DON'T.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
OPPOSE IT.
MIGHT BE A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH IT.
BUT WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE--UNDERSTAND IS
THEY DON'T NEED
TO BE COMFORTABLE.
THEY JUST NEED TO SAY,
"I DON'T NEED TO BE COMFORTABLE.
"THOSE PEOPLE--
WE HAVE A RIGHT.
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO MARRY
THE PERSON THEY LOVE."
THAT SIMPLE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE
TO GET COMFORTABLE WITH.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA
COMMUNICATE TO THEM.
WE HAVE TO COMMUNICATE
ON THEIR LANGUAGE--
WITH THEIR LANGUAGE.
STARTING FROM WHERE
THEY COME FROM
AND BRING 'EM HOME
TO A "NO" VOTE.
ABSOLUTELY DOABLE.
WE'RE GONNA GO UP
ON THE TELEVISION.
ON THE TELEVISION
THE FIRST WEEK IN OCTOBER.
THE REAL QUESTION IS
ARE WE GONNA GET TO GO UP
ON THE TELEVISION EARLIER?
BECAUSE WHOEVER GETS UP
ON THE TELEVISION FIRST
WILL PROBABLY
WIN THIS CAMPAIGN.
SOME FUNNY THINGS I--
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
SEVERAL TIMES HERE.
I'VE DONE MORE CAMPAIGNS THAN,
FRANKLY,
I WANNA THINK ABOUT.
YES, I AM AS OLD AS I LOOK.
[chuckling]
MOST OF IT HAS BEEN TAKEN OUT
OF ME IN CAMPAIGNS.
ALMOST EVERY TIME
ONE SIDE
OR THE OTHER GETS UP--
IT CAN ONLY BE A MATTER
OF A FEW DAYS,
IT COULD BE A WEEK--
AND THEY ESSENTIALLY PUT OUT
AN AD THAT DEFINES THE RACE,
GUESS WHAT?
IF THEY GO UP,
GOD KNOWS HOW
THEY'LL DEFINE
THE RACE ACTUALLY.
LATELY WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT BIGAMY.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT,
"ARE WE GOING TO TEACH
OUR KIDS IN KINDERGARTEN?"
WE'VE HEARD,
"OH, DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP.
YOU DON'T NEED THIS."
WE'VE HEARD A BUNCH OF STUFF
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH, "SHOULD PEOPLE
BE ALLOWED TO MARRY
THE PERSON THEY LOVE?"
IF WE GO UP,
WHAT ARE WE GONNA TALK ABOUT?
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT,
"SHOULD PEOPLE BE ALLOWED
TO MARRY THE PERSON THEY LOVE?"
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT,
"DON'T ELIMINATE THOSE PEOPLE'S
"RIGHTS TO GET MARRIED.
DON'T TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY."
THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT.
THAT IS WHAT'S
ON THE BALLOT.
THAT'S THE DECISION.
THE OTHER SIDE GETS UP FIRST
AND MAKES THIS ABOUT
ALL SORTS OF OTHER STUFF?
I'M GONNA END UP, AND THE WHOLE
COALITION IS GONNA END UP,
SPENDING TWO OR THREE WEEKS
TRYING TO STRAIGHTEN OUT
IN PEOPLE'S HEADS
WHAT THIS CAMPAIGN IS ABOUT.
WE DON'T HAVE THE TIME
TO DO THAT.
WE NEED TO JUST GO
AND MAKE OUR CASE,
TELL 'EM WHAT IT'S ABOUT,
AND THEN--
THIS IS CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE DO BELIEVE IN FREEDOM.
THEY DO BELIEVE
IN OTHER PEOPLE'S RIGHTS.
AND WE'LL WIN THIS RACE.
BUT WE ONLY DO IT
IF WE GET UP THERE FIRST
AND TELL 'EM, YOU KNOW,
"THIS IS IT.
"DON'T BELIEVE ALL THE CRAP,
FRANKLY,
COMING FROM THE OTHER SIDE."
THANK YOU.
MORE THAN WILLING
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
LaJeunesse: PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THANKING OUR PANELISTS.
[applause]
ALL RIGHT,
SO THE MICS ARE OPEN.
IF ANY OF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS,
PLEASE JUST GO
TO ONE OF THE MICS AND THEN
FOR THE SATELLITE OFFICES
WHO ARE JOINING US BY V.C.,
WE'LL ALSO
BE TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS.
WE'LL JUST TAKE A COUPLE
FROM THE LIVE AUDIENCE
FIRST.
man: HI. I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR ALL BEING HERE.
I'VE MET SEVERAL
OF YOU BEFORE.
I KNOW YOU'RE DOING
INCREDIBLE WORK.
I AM GETTING MARRIED
TO MY SAME-SEX PARTNER
IN A WEEK AND HALF, AND I WOULD
RATHER NOT HAVE TO DEAL
WITH LEGAL CONFUSIONS
COME POST-NOVEMBER.
AND WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO ME AFTER 25 YEARS
OF BEING WITH THIS MAN,
IS THAT NOBODY ELSE
HAS TO WAIT 25 YEARS
BEFORE THEIR STATE
CATCHES UP WITH THEM.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS,
IF I MAY.
ONE IS...
WHEN TALKING TO CORPORATIONS,
HOW DO YOU MAKE
WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY HAS
TO BE A BUSINESS CASE
THAT THEY SHOULD
OPPOSE PROPOSITION 8
AND THAT THEY SHOULD LAY OUT
CASH TO DO IT?
Kendell: WELL, I THINK
ONE THING THAT'S GOOD
ABOUT BEING IN A STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA
IS THAT THE FIRST PART OF THAT
IS A PRETTY EASY CASE TO MAKE.
WE LIVE IN A STATE WHERE--
IN A COUNTRY, ACTUALLY--
WHERE THE VAST MAJORITY
OF FORTUNE 500 COMPANIES
HAVE NON-DISCRIMINATION
POLICIES,
HAVE LGBT EMPLOYEE GROUPS
AND BENNET HEADS THE ONE
HERE AT GOOGLE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN,
BENNET.
AND IT'S JUST A PART
OF THE WORKFORCE,
AND IT'S A PART OF RETAINING
THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST.
NOT SAYING THAT LESBIAN
AND GAY PEOPLE
ARE SMARTER THAN MOST PEOPLE,
BUT WE'RE A PART OF THE POOL
OF PEOPLE THAT YOU WANT
TO RETAIN.
AND IT'S A PART OF GOOD BUSINESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU--
THERE'S NO BARRIER
TO THE BEST EMPLOYEE
WANTING TO COME WORK FOR YOU.
SO THAT'S A PRETTY EASY CASE
TO MAKE IN CALIFORNIA,
AND BUSINESSES GET THAT.
THE SECOND PIECE
IS A LITTLE BIT HARDER,
BUT THIS IS WHAT WE'RE FINDING.
AND WITH PG&E,
AND LEVI AND STRAUSS COMPANY,
AND AT&T SUPPORTING "NO"
ON PROP 8 AND GIVING MONEY,
WHAT THEY'RE RECOGNIZING
IS WE'RE PAST THE TIME
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT'S ENOUGH TO SAY--
TO RETAIN THE BEST
AND THE BRIGHTEST,
WE HAVE NON-DISCRIMINATION
POLICIES.
WE HAVE A LGBT GROUP.
EVERYONE IS UNDERSTANDING
THIS IS THE FIGHT
THAT DEFINES EXACTLY WHAT KIND
OF WORKPLACE YOU ARE
AND WHAT
THE BUSINESS COMMITMENT IS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WORDS
ON A PAPER.
IT'S NOT ABOUT
A CORPORATE EQUALITY INDEX
OF ANY ONE PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION.
IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PROP 8 IS DEFEATED.
AND WE FOUND AS PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TALKING TO LOTS
OF DIFFERENT CORPORATIONS
IN THE SILICON VALLEY
AS PART OF OUR BUSINESS COUNSEL,
AND IF ANY OF YOU
HAVE CONNECTIONS
TO CORPORATIONS--
GOOGLE, OBVIOUSLY,
WOULD BE NUMBER ONE ON THAT,
BUT OTHERS AS WELL,
YOU SHOULD TALK TO ME,
AND I CAN PUT YOU IN TOUCH
WITH THE BUSINESS COUNSEL
BECAUSE WE FOUND
THAT THAT MESSAGE WORKS,
AND THEN WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS THE OTHER
NUMBER ONE THING
THAT GETS MONEY
FROM CORPORATIONS?
MONEY THAT COMES
FROM THEIR COMPETITORS.
SO IF GOOGLE JUMPS FIRST
PUBLICLY IN THE SILICON VALLEY,
YOU GET THE HIT OF BEING FIRST,
AND THEN EVERYONE ELSE
WILL COME ALONG.
AND IF GOOGLE DOESN'T GO FIRST,
THAT'S FINE.
SOMEBODY'S GOING FIRST, AND
THAT'S IN PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
BUT BOTH THOSE THINGS WE FIND
ARE REALLY EFFECTIVE.
man: OKAY,
JUST AS A MINOR CORRECTION,
I WOULD NEVER SAY I WAS HEAD
OF THE GAYGLERS GROUP.
WE HAVE A WHOLE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND EVERYTHING.
I'M THE "COORDINATOR,"
WHICH SOUNDS VERY GAY,
AND RIGHTLY SO, AND
IT'S A MUCH WEAKER POSITION,
BELIEVE ME.
Kendell: WELL, THEY CALL ME
THE HEAD LESBIAN, SO I JUST--
man: YEAH, OKAY.
THE OTHER QUESTION
AND THIS IS THE THING
THAT FRUSTRATES
ME THE MOST
AND THAT I'M
MOST SCARED OF, REALLY--
IS THAT THE ISSUE IS FRAMED,
AND NOT ONLY
JUST BY OUR OPPONENTS,
AS GAYS VERSUS CHRISTIANS,
GAYS VERSUS PEOPLE OF FAITH,
GAYS VERSUS FAMILIES.
AND EVEN THE NEWSPAPERS
WILL CALL
DONALD WILDMON'S ORGANIZATION--
I MEAN, IT'S GOT A NAME,
AMERICAN FAMILY ASSOCIATION.
THEY CAN USE THE NAME AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED.
BUT THEY'LL ALSO CALL IT
A FAMILY ORGANIZATION.
A CHRISTIAN ORGANIZATION.
AND I KNOW ENOUGH FAMILIES
AND ENOUGH CHRISTIANS
TO KNOW THAT WHAT THAT IS IS
REALLY AN ANTI-GAY ORGANIZATION
WITH A FUNNY NAME.
UM, HOW--AND THAT FRAMING
SEEMS SO EMBEDDED
IN ALL CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS.
THE WAY THE TELEVISION SHOWS
WILL INTRODUCE
ONE GAY PERSON
AND ONE CHRISTIAN.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
TO SHIFT THAT?
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE WAY WE LOSE.
Kendell: YEAH,
GOOD POINT.
Guerriero: A COUPLE OF POINTS,
AND I'LL LET STEVE
GET TO THE CORE OF THE MESSAGING
PIECE TO IT, IS ONE,
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
WE'RE PROBABLY NOT GONNA CHANGE
SOME OF THAT FRAMEWORK
WITHIN 60 DAYS,
WHICH IS A TOUGH THING
TO SEE.
BUT WE CAN CHANGE
THE FRAMEWORK BY WHICH PEOPLE
LOOK AT CIVIL MARRIAGE
LICENSES.
AND SO, YES, WE CAN PUSH TO HAVE
REALLY SMART SPOKESPERSONS
WHO CAN SPEAK
WITH A LEVEL OF RELIGIOSITY
ON THE NEWS AND IN NEWSPAPERS,
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE DONE.
BUT WE ALSO AREN'T GONNA CHANGE
THIS GREATER FRAMEWORK
ALL THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA,
AND NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT,
AS I THINK WAS
REALLY SMARTLY DONE
ON THE DAY
OF THE FIRST MARRIAGES,
THAT THERE WAS
A WONDERFUL CELEBRATION,
AND IT WAS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT IT WAS CLEARLY
CIVIL MARRIAGE LICENSES.
PEOPLE WALKING INTO CITY HALLS
AND TOWN HALLS
GETTING A PIECE OF PAPER
AND RECOGNIZING THEIR
SOMETIMES HALF
A CENTURY RELATIONSHIP.
AND SO IT DIFFUSES
THAT SWING-VOTER'S SENSE OF,
"IS THIS ABOUT
MY OWN MARRIAGE OR NOT?"
BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH
A TIGHT TIMELINE.
WHAT WE'VE FOUND JUST
IN ONE OTHER STATE
WHERE WE'VE HAD
SOME EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
IS THAT WHEN THE PUBLIC SAW
INDIVIDUALS ASKING
FOR A PIECE OF PAPER,
A LICENSE TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR RELATIONSHIP
IN MASSACHUSETTS,
THAT SWING VOTER ENDED UP MOVING
JUST SLIGHTLY TO OUR SIDE,
WHICH IS WHY STEVE'S POINT
ABOUT FRAMING THIS ARGUMENT
REALLY FAST
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
ABOUT THAT VERSUS
THE QUESTIONS THAT OTHERS
WOULD WANNA PROPOSE,
I THINK IS THE CRITICAL
LYNCHPIN TO WINNING.
Smith: GOOD NEWS
AND BAD NEWS HERE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS--THIS IS
GONNA SOUND REALLY FUNNY--
THAT THE FUNDAMENTALIST CHURCHES
ARE GONNA PUT 40,000--
THEY'RE GONNA TRY
TO PUT 40,000 PEOPLE
IN QUALCOMM STADIUM
FOR A PRAYER VIGIL ON THE SUNDAY
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS FUNNY
I'M SAYING IT'S GOOD NEWS.
FOR UNDECIDED VOTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
THEY ARE A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THAT NOTION, FRANKLY.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS LEADING UP TO THAT,
WE'RE GONNA TAKE SOME RECOGNIZED
RELIGIOUS LEADERS IN THIS STATE
AND HAVE THEM IN QUIET TONES,
NOT SORT OF THREATENING
AND RHETORICAL AND ALL THAT,
TALK ABOUT...
WHAT'S REAL.
THAT, IN FACT, LOVE, COMMITMENT,
MARRIAGE,
FAMILIES IS NOT EXCLUSIVE
TO STRAIGHT CALIFORNIANS.
AND THAT'S GONNA CUT
ON THAT ISSUE, AND I THINK
IT PROBABLY WORKS REAL WELL
WITH THEIR BASE
THAT THE FOLKS COULD
GET REALLY EXCITED,
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST
WHO THEY ARE.
I THINK FOR "UNDECIDED,"
FOR THAT 20% IN THE MIDDLE,
THAT'S GONNA END UP CUTTING
OUR WAY SLIGHTLY
IF WE HANDLE IT WELL.
Guerriero: AND ONE QUICK
FOOTNOTE.
IF EVERY SINGLE LGBT PERSON
IN THIS STATE,
AND OUR FRIENDS,
AND FAMILY, AND ALLIES,
JUST SENT TO THEIR
EMAIL UNIVERSE A STATEMENT,
"MY FAMILY IS ON THE BALLOT
THIS NOVEMBER,"
THAT ALONE COULD BE WORTH
A COUPLE POINTS
THAT DETERMINE WINNING
AND LOSING.
AND WE DISCOVERED ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COUNTRY
THAT SOME OF THE MOST
PASSIONATE LGBT ACTIVISTS
NEVER ASKED THEIR OWN FAMILY
FOR A VOTE.
AND LET'S NOT MAKE THAT MISTAKE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA
'CAUSE THAT COULD ACTUALLY BE
THE DIFFERENCE ON TOP
OF THE ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN.
man: SO LET ME START
BY MENTIONING AN ANECDOTE.
A FRIEND OF MINE WAS DOING
SOME CANVASSING IN PALO ALTO,
AND HE SAID THERE WERE MULTIPLE
PEOPLE HE RAN INTO
WHO SAID, "OH, YES, I SUPPORT
GAY PEOPLE TO MARRIAGE.
I'M GONNA VOTE 'YES' ON 8."
[chuckling]
HE WAS LIKE,
"UNGH! STOP!"
SO, I MEAN, THAT--
OBVIOUSLY, YOU GUYS KNOW
HOW TO HANDLE THAT ONE.
I JUST THOUGHT I'D MENTION
THE ANECDOTE
THAT EVEN JUST LAST WEEKEND
HE WAS STILL GETTING THAT.
IT'S A PROBLEM.
BUT MY QUESTION IS--
SO I'VE ALREADY GIVEN MORE--
ACTUALLY TEN TIMES MORE MONEY
TO THIS CAMPAIGN
THAN I'VE EVER GIVEN
TO ANY OTHER POLITICAL THING.
UM, WHAT ELSE CAN I DO?
[laughter]
I MEAN,
IS THAT THE ONLY THING?
Smith: NO.
Kendell: NO, IT'S NOT
THE ONLY THING.
AND LISTEN,
LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU FOR GIVING,
AND IF EVERYONE GAVE
TEN TIMES WHAT THEY'VE GIVEN
TO ANYTHING ELSE,
WE WOULD WIN THIS THING.
SO THAT IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER THING YOU CAN DO.
THERE ARE ACTION ITEMS
ON THE NOONPROP8.COM WEBSITE,
AND THE BIGGEST THINGS
THAT YOU CAN DO
ARE WHAT PATRICK ALLUDED TO.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S NEVER
ANYONE WHO KNOWS YOU
THAT DOESN'T KNOW
THEY SHOULD VOTE NO.
FROM YOUR DRY CLEANER,
THE MOST INCIDENTAL CONTACTS,
TO THE MOST
SUBSTANTIAL CONTACTS.
WAKING UP EVERY DAY SAYING,
"WHO DO I TALK TO TODAY?
WHAT CAN I DO TODAY
TO DEFEAT PROP 8?"
LETTERS TO FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
THERE'S A WHOLE
GOOGLE NETWORK OF FOLKS
THAT PROBABLY HAVEN'T GIVEN
AND DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THIS.
ASKING PEOPLE TO GIVE, WHICH
YOU MAY NOT HAVE DONE BEFORE.
WE CAN GIVE YOU TEMPLATES
FOR BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND THEN ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE CAMPAIGN,
THE FIELD COMPONENT
OF THE CAMPAIGN.
AND THERE IS AN OFFICE
DOWN HERE
IN--I THINK IT'S IN SAN JOSE
IS THE FIELD OFFICE.
BUT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY CONTACT ME DIRECTLY
AND I'LL PUT YOU IN TOUCH WITH
FOLKS TO DO SOME PHONE BANKING.
EVEN THOUGH--
WHAT YOU'RE PHONE BANKING--
IS YOU'RE NOT DOING COLD CALLS.
AND I UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"OOH, I JUST DON'T WANNA CALL
STRANGERS."
BUT LET ME JUST SAY
TO STEVE'S EARLIER POINT,
WE WILL WIN THIS WITHIN
THE MARGIN OF ERROR.
THAT MARGIN OF ERROR
COULD BE, YOU KNOW,
MICHAEL PHELPS' FINGERNAIL
IS WHAT WE SAY IN THE CAMPAIGN.
AND THAT COULD BE
THE 250,000 VOTERS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CALL,
PHONE BANKING,
ASKING THEM TO VOTE NO.
GRAB A BUNCH OF YOUR FRIENDS.
GO OUT AND MAKE A NIGHT OF IT.
TWO HOURS PHONE BANKING,
TAKE 'EM OUT
FOR A COUPLE OF PITCHERS,
AND YOU WILL HAVE DONE
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
IN ADDITION
TO THE OTHER LIST OF THINGS.
Guerriero: THE PITCHERS
BEFORE OR AFTER THE CALLS?
Kendell: WELL, YOU KNOW,
IT JUST DEPENDS.
I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU.
Smith: DO YOU GET BETTER?
LaJeunesse: ALL RIGHT,
WHY DON'T WE TAKE A QUESTION
FROM ONE OF THE SATELLITE
OFFICES, REMOTE OFFICES, BY--
IT'S AUDIO, RIGHT--
JUST AUDIO?
ANYONE OUT THERE HAVE
A QUESTION FOR OUR PANEL?
GOING ONCE, GOING TWICE.
man: CAN YOU CLARIFY TO PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
[man speaking indistinctly]
LaJeunesse: OKAY, DO YOU WANNA
MAKE THAT POINT?
Kendell: OH, YES.
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE.
INTERNATIONALLY?
Smith: NO.
LaJeunesse: I'M SORRY,
THE QUESTION WAS TO CLARIFY
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHERE
YOU RESIDE, YOU ARE LEGALLY
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE CAMPAIGN.
Kendell: YES, YOU HAVE TO BE
A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT--
man: OR GREEN CARDS.
OR GREEN CARD HOLDERS.
Kendell: OR GREEN CARD HOLDER,
THANK YOU, YES.
OR GREEN CARD HOLDER.
YOU ALL WOULD KNOW THAT,
WOULDN'T YOU?
YES.
AND YOU CAN GIVE MONEY
TO THE CAMPAIGN
EITHER THROUGH THE WEBSITE--
YOU CAN--
THERE'S A WAY TO GIVE THERE
OR CONTACT THE WEBSITE ABOUT--
THE CONTACT INFORMATION THERE
ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE A GIFT.
ABOVE THE THE $10 MILLION
THAT YOU SEE THERE
AND THE $32,000 THAT WE--
OR 32,000 DONORS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER,
A SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE,
NOT A MAJORITY, OF COURSE,
BUT A SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE
IS FROM OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A STATE
THAT WON'T BE TOUCHED, AS
PATRICK TALKED ABOUT, BY THIS.
SO NO MATTER
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE--
SO IF YOU HAVE
WEALTHY FRIENDS OR FAMILY
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA
WHO YOU THINK WOULD BE WILLING
TO MAKE A CONTRIBUTION,
WE WILL DO WHATEVER
WE NEED TO DO
AT THE CAMPAIGN TO HELP YOU
FACILITATE THAT.
WE WILL PROVIDE YOU
TALKING POINTS,
A SAMPLE LETTER,
WALK YOU THROUGH IT.
YOU KNOW, I'LL GET
ON THE PHONE MYSELF WITH 'EM
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE
OF THE GIFT.
[laughter]
AND YOU CAN--FROM ANYWHERE
YOU LIVE YOU CAN GIVE.
YES, GOOD QUESTION.
woman: I WANNA GO BACK TO THE
FRAMING AND MESSAGING DISCUSSION
ALTHOUGH STEVEN PARTLY
ADDRESSED, YOU KNOW,
WHAT I HAD AS A QUESTION.
SO WHAT WE'VE HEARD HERE
IS IT'S NOT--
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
IN THE 20%,
YOU DON'T NEED TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH IT,
IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW,
SOMEONE ELSE'S BUSINESS,
WHICH IS A GREAT PROGRESSIVE,
A GREAT, YOU KNOW,
LIBERTARIAN ARGUMENT,
BUT I'M CONCERNED HOW IT GETS
TO THE CHRISTIAN BASE.
THEN WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS,
YOU KNOW,
SOMEONE'S FAMILY
IS ON THE LINE.
WHICH IS ALSO A GREAT ARGUMENT,
BUT IT'S A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A "PETA" ARGUMENT IN THERE
IS SOME CONDESCENSION OF, LIKE,
THE STRAIGHT MAJORITY RELATING
TO THE LGBT MINORITY.
SO, AGAIN, I'M WONDERING
TO WHAT EXTENT IT GETS
TO THE CHRISTIAN BASE.
SO I'M THINKING THAT
WHAT I DON'T HEAR IS, LIKE,
REALLY POSITIVE, LIKE,
AFFIRMATIVE ARGUMENTS.
LET'S SAY BECAUSE
THE LGBT MINORITY WANTS TO JOIN
AND IS JOINING IN THE
INSTITUTION OF MARRIAGE ITSELF,
IT ACTUALLY AFFIRMS
THE MARRIAGES OF, YOU KNOW,
CHRISTIAN PEOPLE,
'CAUSE I'VE HEARD IN SOME STATES
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO, LIKE,
REMARRY BECAUSE THEY FEEL
THAT, YOU KNOW,
GAY MARRIAGE HAS THREATENED
THEIR SACRED INSTITUTION
OF MARRIAGE AND, YOU KNOW,
ALL OF THAT STUFF.
SO IT SEEMS THAT IT
CAN BE SWITCHED.
LIKE, THE ARGUMENT CAN BE
SWITCHED AND SAY,
"LOOK, YOUR INSTITUTION
OF MARRIAGE IS, YOU KNOW,
"REAFFIRMED BY VOTING NO
TO THE PROPOSITION.
"YOU'RE REAFFIRMING YOUR OWN,
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW,
CHRISTIAN, IF NEED,
THE INSTITUTION."
SO I JUST HAVEN'T HEARD THAT,
AND I'M WONDERING
IF THERE'LL BE ANYTHING.
Smith: WHAT--IF I WERE
TO GO DOWN THAT PATH,
THE WAY I WOULD
SAY THAT PRECISELY--
AND I GOTTA SAY WORDS
IN THIS THING MATTER A LOT.
woman: YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
Smith: I WOULD SAY
DON'T LIMIT--
DON'T ELIMINATE OUR RIGHT
TO AFFIRM MARRIAGE.
TO JOIN THE--I MEAN, WE--
GAY AND LESBIAN PEOPLE
WANNA STAND UP
AND SHARE
IN THE RESPONSIBILITY,
THE COMMITMENT,
THE JOY OF MARRIAGE.
DON'T ELIMINATE
OUR RIGHT TO DO THAT.
SO I'D TAKE IT THAT ONE STEP.
YES, MAKE IT POSITIVE,
MAKE IT AFFIRMING,
BUT THEN DO THE ELIMINATION
AT THE END
BECAUSE, IN FACT,
THAT'S WHAT MOTIVATES FOLKS.
woman: HAVE THERE BEEN STUDIES
ON--AS TO HOW WORDING CHANGES,
LIKE, POLL RESULTS?
LIKE, WHAT IS THE DATA?
Smith: LET ME GIVE YOU JUST
ONE LITTLE EXAMPLE,
AND IT'S A LITTLE OFF.
BUT IF--TO--
CLEARLY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
TREATING PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY,
ANOTHER WAY TO SAY THAT
IS "DISCRIMINATE."
IF YOU USE "DISCRIMINATE,"
ABOUT 10, 15% OF THE PEOPLE
WON'T BUY IT AS WELL
AS IF YOU JUST SAY,
"TREAT PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY."
YOU GET A 10-15%
DIFFERENT REA--
THAT'S WHY THE WORD
"ELIMINATE" IS SO--
THE WORD "ELIMINATE"
IS PROBABLY WORTH TEN POINTS.
JUST USING THAT WORD.
SO THAT'S WHY I SAY
WHEN YOU MAKE
THE POSITIVE AFFIRMING,
"YEAH, WE WANT IT.
"WE WANT THE RESPONSIBILITY.
WE WANT THE COMMITMENT."
DON'T ELIMINATE OUR RIGHT
TO DO THAT.
woman: OKAY.
LaJeunesse: AND RIGHT HERE.
man: I THINK YOU ACTUALLY JUST
ANSWERED MY QUESTION.
MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE,
IN OCTOBER WHEN YOU GO
ONTO THE AIRWAVES, ARE YOU GOING
TO BE PUTTING FORWARD
A POSITIVE MESSAGE SAYING,
YOU KNOW, "EQUALITY TO ALL,"
OR ARE YOU GOING TO BE SAYING,
"DON'T DESTROY OUR MARRIAGE"?
Smith: WE'RE GONNA--IT'S A
POSITIVE MESSAGE TO SOME DEGREE.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY,
AND THIS GOES BACK TO--
I FORGET WHO IT WAS EARLIER
THAT SAID
THERE IS CONFUSION OUT THERE.
EVERY AD YOU SEE US DO
AT THE END WILL BE A NEGATIVE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A "NO,"
YOU KNOW?
VOTE NO ON 8.
WE CAN'T ALLOW ANY CONFUSION
ABOUT THAT AT THE END.
LaJeunesse: STEVE, COULD YOU
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
VOTERS WHO ARE UNDECIDED
AT THE LAST MINUTE
GENERALLY GO TOWARD
THE "NO" ANYWAY, RIGHT?
Smith: YEAH.
LaJeunesse: IF THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT,
BUT THEY'RE NOT SURE,
IT GOES "NO," IS--
Smith: RIGHT, GENERALLY,
IF YOU'RE PUSHING A "YES" VOTE
YOU HAVE A BIGGER BURDEN
THAN IF YOU'RE PUSHING
A "NO" VOTE,
GENERALLY, IN MOST ELECTIONS.
SO IF FOLKS GO INTO A VOTING
BOOTH AND THEY'RE NOT SURE YET,
PEOPLE ARE KINDA, YOU KNOW--
THEY GET NERVOUS
ABOUT CHANGE, FRANKLY.
SO IF THEY HAVEN'T REALLY
MADE UP THEIR MIND,
YOU'RE LIKELY
TO GET A "NO" VOTE.
THE ONE THING I WILL SAY THAT
MAKES THIS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
IS IN SOME PEOPLE'S HEADS,
WE'RE THE ONES
LOOKING FOR THE CHANGE NOW
BECAUSE MARRIAGE
IS RELATIVELY RECENT.
SO WE HAVE A SLIGHT TINGE
ON THAT,
BUT WE STILL HAVE
TO DRIVE A, YOU KNOW,
"VOTE NO ON 8."
AND AS YOU HAVE
ALL YOUR CONVERSATIONS--
AND I WANNA AGAIN SAY,
ONE ON ONES
PUTTING IT ON THE BASIS
TO YOUR FRIENDS OF,
"HEY, THIS VOTE IS ABOUT ME.
PROPOSITION 8,
YOU'RE VOTING ON ME."
YOU'RE GONNA PULL
SOME FRIENDS THAT WAY.
THEY KNOW YOU.
Guerriero: SINCE I'M
THE LEAST--
man: "VOTE NO ON ME."
Guerriero: "VOTE NO
ON ME"?
THAT MIGHT WORK
WITH SOME OF OUR ENEMIES.
Smith: THOSE ARE YOUR ENEMIES,
YEAH, RIGHT?
Guerriero: SINCE I'M THE LEAST
POLITICALLY CORRECT UP HERE,
I DO WANNA NOTE ONE THING
ABOUT THIS CAMPAIGN.
IS THAT IF I'M COMPLETELY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE AD
THAT STEVE PUTS UP
IN A FEW WEEKS,
WE'LL PROBABLY LOSE.
IF YOU'RE COMPLETELY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE AD YOU SEE,
AND IT MOVES YOU
IN A SPECIAL PLACE,
IT'S PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT AD
TO MOVE THOSE PEOPLE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO
ONCE WE ANALYZE A CAMPAIGN,
AND THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE,
AND THE DATA, AND THE POLLING,
AND RESEARCH,
AT SOME POINT, WE STEP BACK
AND SAY, "HE KNOWS--
OR, "WE BELIEVE
HE IS TOTALLY CAPABLE
OF FIGURING OUT WHAT
THAT MESSAGE IS."
AND THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY,
MAYBE EVEN
THE PROGRESSIVE COMMUNITY,
THAT DON'T LIKE THAT AD,
OR DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT THE AD MIGHT CHANGE
TEN DAYS LATER
DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE OTHER SIDE DOES.
AND FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN
AROUND THE COUNTRY,
MOST OF THE TIMES
THE LGBT MOVEMENT
HAS NEVER BEEN ABLE TO PULL
BACK. AND ENDED UP
MICROMANAGING THE MESSAGE,
AND CRITIQUING THE MESSAGE.
AND WE ENDED UP WITH A MESSAGE
THAT MADE US FEEL REALLY GOOD
AT NIGHT
UNTIL ELECTION NIGHT.
AND SO A BIG,
BOLD STEP FOR ALL OF US,
INCLUDING THOSE OF US WHO ARE
INVESTING BIG-TIME IN THIS,
IS TO COME TO A PLACE WHERE
WE JUST KIND OF EMBRACE THAT
AND ACCEPT STEPPING
OUT OF CONTROL,
TRUSTING THAT THERE'S
A REAL SMART TEAM IN PLACE.
SO THAT'S A TOUGH THING
FOR ALL OF US,
AND I'M SURE ALL OF US
IN THE ROOM TODAY.
LaJeunesse: WHY DON'T WE SWITCH
OFF AND GO OVER HERE?
man: YOU ALMOST ANSWERED
MY SECOND QUESTION.
BUT THERE ARE REALLY TWO THINGS
THAT SCARE ME ABOUT THIS THING.
WHICH IS, NUMBER ONE,
WHAT I'M GONNA CALL
"THE DAVID DUKE EFFECT."
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE POLLS
MAY SHOW THEY'RE EQUAL,
BUT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LIE
AND TELL THE POLLSTERS
WHAT THEY THINK THE POLLSTERS
WANNA HEAR RATHER THAN
WHAT THEY WANNA FEEL.
AND THE SECOND IS,
CAN THE GAY COMMUNITY
REALLY MAKE HARD-HEADED
POLITICAL DECISIONS?
I KEEP ON THINKING
OF WHAT RECENTLY
HAPPENED WITH HRC AND ENDA,
WHERE HRC MADE
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS NOT THE
POLITICALLY CORRECT DECISION,
BUT THE POLITICALLY--
THE CORRECT POLITICAL DECISION,
AND THEY JUST GOT RAMMED
FOR IT.
YOU KNOW, EVERYONE
HATED THEM AS A RESULT, SO.
Guerriero: I'LL DEFEND YOU
FOR A SECOND HERE.
IN THE SENSE THAT THE GOOD
NEWS IS, UNLIKE THE HRC MODEL,
WHICH WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCE FOR THE COMMUNITY,
AND DIVIDED REALLY
WELL INTENTIONED PEOPLE,
IS THAT TO THE CREDIT
OF KATE AND MANY OTHER
OF THE LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA,
THERE HAS BEEN
A TWO, THREE-YEAR PROCESS
OF GETTING TO A PLACE
WHERE WE KNEW THIS CAMPAIGN
WAS GONNA HAPPEN
AT SOME POINT.
AND LITERALLY, FROM THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF,
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THIS CAMPAIGN
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE
ULTIMATELY UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
WHEN IT COMES TO EVERY
STRATEGIC DECISION.
AND SO, NO, THERE ISN'T
A HISTORY OF DOING IT.
THIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE COALITION GROUPS,
I THINK, HAVE A
VERY CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT'S GONNA BE THE CASE,
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN NOW
AND ELECTION DAY.
AND IF WE DON'T OVERCOME THAT,
WE WILL LOSE.
AND THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A VERY
LEGITIMATE CONCERN.
Kendell: YEAH, AND I COULD
JUST SAY, I MEAN,
WE'RE ALREADY KNEE-DEEP
IN MESSAGING AT THIS POINT.
AND, YOU KNOW,
THE MESSAGING IS BASED ON
WHAT THE POLLS
AND THE FOCUS GROUP SAYS.
IT'S NOT BASED ON THE AD
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE,
YOU KNOW, AS A RADICAL,
LESBIAN FEMINIST,
YOU KNOW, UP ON THE TV.
SO--AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT.
Smith: I'VE HEARD THAT
ABOUT YOU.
I'VE HEARD THAT
Kendell: AND WE REALLY HAVEN'T
HAD A DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THAT.
I WILL--I JUST HAVE TO NOTE,
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
COMPLETELY DISAGREE
ABOUT YOUR CHARACTERIZATION
ABOUT THE HRC THING.
AND IT'S NOT A POLITICAL CORRECT
OR NOT.
I THINK, STRATEGICALLY,
IT WAS A BAD DECISION.
BUT I'M JUST SAYING THAT.
I DON'T WANNA
GET OFF POINT ABOUT IT,
BUT I JUST HAVE
TO BOOKMARK IT.
man: I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
Kendell: BUT TO THE BIGGER ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE RAISING,
WE ARE COMPLETELY ON BOARD
WITH WINNING.
I WANNA WAKE UP
NOVEMBER 5th KNOWING--
I MEAN, I'M GONNA WAKE UP
KNOWING THAT I DID
EVERYTHING I POSSIBLY COULD.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
I COULD HAVE DONE
TO DEFEAT PROP 8.
I DON'T WANNA BE
SECOND GUESSING ANYTHING
THAT I DID OR MY LEVEL
OF COMMITMENT.
AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
GONNA LOSE IT
BECAUSE I WAS WEDDED
TO MESSAGING THAT I LIKED
THAT WAS NOT DRIVEN
AND SUPPORTED
BY THE DATA.
Smith: AND LET ME
JUST FINISH OUT THE RESPONSE
TO YOUR FIRST PART
OF YOUR QUESTION.
IF WE DON'T WALK IN THERE WITH
A 10-POINT LEAD IN THE POLLS,
WE'RE IN TROUBLE.
man: OKAY, THANK YOU.
Smith: I MEAN,
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
woman: UM, MY QUESTION RELATES
TO THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
THE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
UPON THE STATE IF PROP 8 PASSES
OR DOESN'T PASS.
I NOTICED THAT THERE
IS SOMETHING RELATING
TO TOURISM REVENUE,
BUT THERE IS NOTHING
ABOUT THE EFFECT
OF LGBT WORKERS CHOOSING
TO COME TO THE STATE
OR TO LEAVE THE STATE
DEPENDING ON WHAT HAPPENS.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY KIND
OF ANALYSIS DONE ON THIS,
WHETHER IT BE BY THE STATE
OR BY "NO ON PROP 8"?
Guerriero: YEAH, I BELIEVE
THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE AT UCLA
HAS DONE A STUDY
THAT SHOWS THAT FIGURE.
THEY WERE STILL
FINE-TUNING IT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE ACTUAL FINAL REPORT,
BUT THAT IS ONE OF THE,
KIND OF,
MANY TALKING POINTS
THAT WILL BE CIRCULATED
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER,
AND IT'S THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE,
THAT REALLY IS THE BEST
IN THE COUNTRY
AT DOING THAT TYPE OF WORK
FOR THESE BALLOT INITIATIVES.
Kendell: WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE DATA IN TIME
FOR THE FISCAL ANALYST
LANGUAGE.
SO OTHERWISE IT WOULD SAY, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, A BILLION DOLLARS.
AND, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE ENOUGH
TO, YOU KNOW,
DRIVE PEOPLE TO VOTE NO.
BUT IT'S A VERY
WELL TAKEN POINT.
LaJeunesse: WE'RE AT RIGHT
ABOUT 4:00,
AND I WANNA BE RESPECTFUL
OF THE PANELISTS' TIME,
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TIME
FOR ONE MORE QUESTION.
Kendell: YOU BET.
man: THANKS,
I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT MY WIFE AND I KNOW
FIVE LONG-TERM COUPLES
WHO'VE BEEN GETTING MARRIED
WITHIN, ABOUT,
A TWO-MONTH PERIOD HERE,
AND IN EACH CASE,
WE'VE BEEN DONATING
TO "NO ON 8" IN THEIR HONOR.
AS A WEDDING GIFT,
WE FIGURE THAT'S A LITTLE MORE
MEANINGFUL
THAN YET ANOTHER TOASTER OVEN.
[applause]
AND THAT THOSE FIVE COUPLES
INCLUDE, BY THE WAY,
OUR CURRENT PASTOR,
TWO FORMER PASTORS
AND THEIR PARTNERS,
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY
I AND MY WIFE
CERTAINLY RESENT WILDMON
AND THE REST
OF THE RELIGIOUS RIGHT
TRYING TO MONOPOLIZE
THE NAME OF CHRISTIAN,
'CAUSE THEY
CERTAINLY DO NOT SPEAK FOR US.
SO, TWO QUESTIONS.
ONE IS WHAT CAN THE PROGRESSIVE
RELIGIOUS COMMUNITY DO
TO HELP DEFEAT PROPOSITION 8
ASIDE FROM, YOU KNOW,
WHAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING?
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S LIMITS
IN TERMS OF WHAT ONE CAN DO,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF DIRECT
ACTION WITHIN THE CHURCH,
BUT BY BEING LIKE-MINDED PEOPLE,
WE WANNA GET THAT MESSAGE OUT.
AND THEN, ALSO,
I WAS HOPING THAT PATRICK
COULD SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO THE HISTORY
IN MASSACHUSETTS,
AND HOW OPINIONS
HAVE TURNED AROUND THERE
JUST BY THE FACT
OF GAY MARRIAGE
BEING ESTABLISHED.
IT SEEMS, YOU KNOW,
FROM 3,000 MILES AWAY
THAT THAT REALLY HAS TURNED
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE'S OPINIONS
AROUND AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR
A LITTLE MORE ABOUT THAT.
Guerriero: SURE, I'LL MAYBE
CONNECT BOTH QUESTIONS
AND WRAP THEM INTO ONE,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
THAT EVERY TIME
THE RADICAL RIGHT
WOULD GO ON TV,
OR HOLD A PRESS CONFERENCE,
OR ISSUE A PRESS RELEASE,
THE PROGRESSIVE RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITY CHOSE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT I THOUGHT WAS REALLY,
REALLY SMART.
THEY DIDN'T DECIDE
TO DEBATE THE BIBLE
OR THE INTERPRETATION
OF SCRIPTURE.
THEY CHOSE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE TREAT OUR NEIGHBORS.
ABOUT THEIR VIEW OF RELIGIOSITY,
ABOUT CHRISTIANITY,
AND THEY KINDA FLIPPED
THE ENTIRE ARGUMENT
COMPLETELY UPSIDE DOWN.
AND IT WAS BEAUTIFULLY DONE,
BECAUSE THE WORK
TO HAVE A HEAVY-DUTY,
MULTI-SYLLABIC,
RELIGIOUS DEBATE IS ONE
WE ULTIMATELY LOSE
IN A TIGHT TIMEFRAME
ABOUT A COMPLEX ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH.
BUT THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO STAND AT A MICROPHONE,
STAND PUBLICLY, SPEAK
AT PUBLIC HEARINGS AND SAY,
"I'M A MAN OR A WOMAN
WHO BELIEVES IN GOD
"AND BELIEVES THAT MY NEIGHBOR
SHOULD BE TREATED
ABSOLUTELY EQUALLY," UM,
WAS THE BEAUTIFUL COUNTERPOINT.
IT DIDN'T WIN
THE FAR-RIGHT VOTER.
IT DIDN'T, YOU KNOW,
GET TO THAT 40%
THAT AIN'T GONNA BE--
AREN'T GONNA BE WITH US.
BUT IT DID MOVE JUST
THAT SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT NEEDED TO STEP OUR WAY.
AND THEN THE LAST THING I DID--
THE ONLY NEGATIVE PART
ABOUT ALL THE MARRIAGES
IN MASSACHUSETTS
WAS THAT IT'S COST ME
SO MUCH MONEY IN WEDDING GIFTS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
SO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT IS
ACTUALLY NEGATIVE INDIVIDUALLY.
YOU'VE DONE A REALLY--
PROBABLY THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
THING YOU CAN DO
WHICH IS ENSURE THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN NEVER--WON'T HAVE
TO QUESTION WHETHER THEY CAN
MARRY THE PERSON THAT THEY LOVE
AND THAT IS A GREAT ACT
OF CHRISTIANITY
AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT.
AND WE, LIKE YOU,
HAVE REALIZED IN MASSACHUSETTS
THAT ALL OF THE THREATS
OF THE FAR RIGHT
HAVE NOT COME TRUE.
AND THE PUBLIC,
WHICH USED TO BE 35%
SUPPORTING MARRIAGE EQUALITY,
MOVED UP TO 50
ONCE THE WEDDINGS HAPPENED.
MOVED UP TO 55,
AND NOW TWO OUT OF EVERY THREE,
INCLUDING THE MAJORITY
OF REPUBLICANS,
SUPPORT FULL MARRIAGE EQUALITY
FOR EVERYONE IN A STATE.
IT'S A PRETTY
AMAZING PLACE TO LIVE.
AND THIS GREAT STATE'S
GONNA BE THE NEXT ONE
TO EXPERIENCE THAT MILESTONE.
LaJeunesse: DANIELLE,
DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION?
I SAW YOU BY THE MIC.
ARE YOU ALL SET?
JUST ONE LAST QUICK ONE.
COME ON UP.
Danielle: HEY, THANK YOU.
I AM DANIELLE.
I WORK
IN THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE.
AND I AM ONE OF TEN KIDS.
NUMBER THREE OUT OF TEN.
AND I WAS JUST
INSTANT MESSAGING MY DAD.
MY DAD IS
A DIE-HARD REPUBLICAN CATHOLIC,
AND I WAS LIKE, "HEY, DAD,
I'M UP TO MISCHIEF."
AND HE ASKED ME
WHAT I WAS DOING.
AND I MENTIONED WHERE I WAS,
AND HIS QUESTION WAS,
"CAN'T YOU JUST CALL IT
SOMETHING ELSE?"
HE'S LIKE,
"IT'S NOT MARRIAGE.
CAN'T YOU JUST CALL IT
SOMETHING ELSE?"
SO I WANTED TO HAVE YOU GUYS
REALLY PINPOINT
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
AND MARRIAGES ARE.
I HAVEN'T--MY FAMILY
BEING VERY CATHOLIC--
AND THEY'RE FROM PENNSYLVANIA,
SO I SAID,
"DAD, YOU'RE NOT REGISTERED
TO VOTE IN CALIFORNIA,
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER."
Kendell: BUT WE'LL HUMOR YOU
ANYWAY.
Danielle: YEAH, THANK YOU.
Kendell: I--IF I HAD A DOLLAR
FOR EVERY TIME I'VE BEEN ASKED
THAT QUESTION, YOU KNOW,
I COULD FUND THE CAMPAIGN.
AND WHAT I'VE TAKEN TO SAYING
WHEN PEOPLE ASK ME THAT QUESTION
IS I SAY, "WHY?"
'CAUSE THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THEY ASKING?
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS THEY
THINK THERE'S SOMETHING SPECIAL
ABOUT MEN AND WOMEN'S
RELATIONSHIPS
THAT GAY AND LESBIAN COUPLES
DO NOT SHARE.
SO THE WORD "MARRIAGE"
SHOULD BE RESERVED
FOR THOSE REAL RELATIONSHIPS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIPS.
THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT I UNDERSTAND THE MOST.
'CAUSE I DON'T REALLY
GET THIS.
SO ONCE I HEAR
THE ANSWER BACK TO THE,
"TELL ME WHY YOU WOULD LIKE IT
TO BE A DIFFERENT NAME?"
IT GENERALLY UNCOVERS
SOME LEVEL OF DISCOMFORT
WHICH PROVIDES
A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY, BECAUSE THEN
MY NEXT QUESTION IS,
"WELL, LET ME JUST
TURN THE TABLES.
"HOW ABOUT IF WE CALL
YOUR RELATIONSHIP
"A CIVIL UNION
OR A DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP
"AND MINE A MARRIAGE?
WOULD YOU GIVE UP
THE WORD 'MARRIAGE'?"
GIVE UP THE WORD "MARRIAGE"
FOR EVERYONE,
AND EVERYONE
HAS A CIVIL UNION.
NOW, WHILE THAT MIGHT BE
SOME PEOPLE'S IDEA
OF THAT'S A PERFECT SOLUTION
FOR THIS.
AND THEN IF YOU GET MARRIED IN
A CHURCH IT'S CALLED "MARRIAGE,"
THAT'S NOT WHERE WE ARE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
MARRIAGE IS THE INSTITUTION
AND THE VOCABULARY
THAT WE USE TO DENOTE
THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF A COMMITMENT
BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE.
IT IS WHAT WE DO.
AND AS LONG AS WE DO THAT,
GAY AND LESBIAN RELATIONSHIPS
SHOULD NOT BE EXCLUDED
FROM IT.
IT'S AS TERRY STEWART SAID
IN THE ARGUMENT
BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT
WHEN SHE WAS ASKED
THIS VERY QUESTION.
WORDS MATTER.
THERE'S A REASON
WHY THIS LANGUAGE MATTERS
AND WHY YOUR DAD--
WHO SOUNDS LIKE A LOVELY PERSON,
SOUNDS JUST LIKE MY DAD,
WHO I LOVE--
WANTS TO ASK THAT.
BECAUSE HE WANTS IT
TO GO AWAY...
INSTEAD OF A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION THAT SAYS,
"THIS IS ABOUT US
AND OUR RELATIONSHIPS
BEING ABLE TO BE VALIDATED
IN THE SAME WAY."
NO DAD EVER SAID,
"I CAN'T WAIT TO DANCE
AT MY DAUGHTER'S CIVIL UNION,
DOMESTIC PARTNER
COMMITMENT CEREMONY."
WE DANCE
AT OUR CHILDREN'S WEDDINGS.
WE GET MARRIED.
AND AS LONG AS THAT
IS THE WAY WE MARK
IMPORTANCE IN RELATIONSHIPS
AND COMMITMENT,
SAME-SEX COUPLES SHOULD HAVE
THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY.
LaJeunesse: ALL RIGHT.
HELP ME THANK KATE, PAT,
AND STEVE.
[applause]